[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
and lo everyone and welcome to another
day of game sports play for all event we
are streaming for charity across the
summer raising money for black lives
matter as well as Direct Relief links
are below and on screen joining us today
so he got me and more we're joined by
the lovely Brianna white to play some
Final Fantasy 7 remake where she voices
the character of eros welcome Emma thank
you thank you thank you I'm very excited
to be here today didn't it yeah it's
kind of wild that we managed to get you
on given how obsessed we're all we all
are with the game and like we've been
I've been definitely just watching your
streams just to hear you talk about it
and it's I think everyone will probably
have seen the video of you that's been
going do the rounds going viral where
you really yeah so I think a lot of
people will come in through that and I
think we'll probably talk about that
later but we're gonna play an
interesting part of the game that's
quite personal to your character so and
we'll have that in there going while we
discuss your kind of path into into
becoming arguably one of the most iconic
voices in video gaming history so blows
my mind
hear it I don't believe it still yeah so
as we mentioned we're raising money for
black lives matter and covert relief and
you can see both links to donate on the
screen
Bly force - yes - BLM and then GS - Co
vid and we are keeping an eye on the
chat as well both on Twitch and on
YouTube so if you have questions for
Briana
and let us know we'll try and pose them
at a point that is easier for her to
answer no in the middle of the Reno
fight which is what we're about to get
into so we'll do our best though and say
yeah Briana if you want to start playing
kick it off see how we do aren't playing
the game already yeah where are we in
the game exactly because you you're very
sweet and you mentioned that when we
were setting this up you know we wanted
to play a really key part of the story
with regards to Eris and her character
and so there's obviously a fantastic
part in chapter 8 and you you're playing
the game through on your own twitch and
live streaming that
but you don't have to select so you very
kindly replayed it for us just to get to
this point thank you correct I Inge all
the way through chapter 8 last night
that was 8 hours of gameplay almost
exactly it was 7 hours and 52 minutes
Wow yeah so when did you start playing
it cuz it came out what God time has no
meaning anymore I know it was released
like a week before oh my gosh it was
released like a week before in Australia
as well so it was officially released on
April 10th and then I started playing it
I believe a week after on the 17th and
so I've been playing it ever since then
but because I'm playing it on streem I
take it a little bit slowly so I don't
have chapter select yet because I didn't
finish the game and so for me I have to
be very careful what I select here this
is the one because I'm in chapter 14 on
my own playthrough on my own twitch
channel but here I got us all the way
back to meeting Aerith in the church for
the first time thank you I was gonna ask
do you sometimes this is a weird
question to ask but like sometimes when
I listen to a voice or actors or anyone
who plays a character and I hear
elements of the of the character in
there is that something that you
personally do on purpose it's like drop
in a bit of air if and here and there I
you just kind of like naturally speaking
because when you said you were speaking
earlier I was like I just heard
everything my head there I it's not on
purpose
I don't think it's it's very rare that
I'll do it on purpose but sometimes on
stream when people will be saying oh I
love this line or if I'm talking about
another line I'll say it as I'm
referencing the line and then my whole
chat blows up she did the thing and it's
not intentional most of the time just as
I'm naturally speaking so that time you
heard me earlier was not on purpose
okay okay go well I enjoyed it
nevertheless
yeah I've seen it is um a little similar
to my natural speaking voice but there
is a little bit of a difference there um
as in she's a little bit more she's a
little bit higher
obviously in pitch but she's also a lot
breath here and clearer than I normally
speak I kind of you know speak like a
California and I talk from the back of
my throat but arias is a little bit you
know higher in breathy er and and a
little bit more like a like a sweet
Disney princess so it's it's a little
bit different but mostly you know yeah
whenever whenever voice actors do that
where they do a voice it's like magic to
me so I was like yeah that's cool you
know I wouldn't understand it at all if
I hadn't met with Eric Hollenbeck
for my Final Fantasy 7 original
playthrough and she came in she's the
voice of Jesse and remake she came in
and we were just talking about things
and she started doing voices for some of
the characters she was doing and
watching her and listening to her it's
almost like an act of ventriloquist
either voice associated with the
character on the screen and then you
hear it come out of someone else's mouth
and you're like wait a minute yeah
that's exactly there's a moment where
you're kind of you disconnect the person
speaking from themselves and like your
mind just becomes that character
whenever it happens a lot when when
nolan north and troy break choi baekho
did their their series together and I'd
watch it and occasionally did do a voice
and I'd be like this is very strange yes
there was a really cool video of um so
feature Amma Billy West obviously played
so many of the characters that there are
these behind the scenes ones where he's
just talking to himself but when he goes
from like Professor Farnsworth to fry he
changes the way that he sort of moves
his face and like really gets into
character and it is like watching five
different people in one person it said
so wickedly talented AI can I imagine I
really
it's the same with Mark Hamill like ever
since watching the Batman the Animated
Series like I've never been able to
detach Joker from Mark Hamill so when I
see him in Star Wars all I can hear is
like subdue Joker when I see him in
Avatar The Last Airbender I had kind of
firebender Joker everywhere I go is that
yeah I'm actually a little bit worried
about future voice-over work because I
I'm wondering if I'm gonna get
pigeonholed in the same way you know
that but that's Eric's voice we can't
hear her as anything else I think I
think it's my it kind of for me
specifically with Mark Hamill it's it's
it's a thing in my own life where I've
heard it so much that I can't disconnect
it but like most voice actors like
yourself are great at you know varying
it up and and kind of making it sound
different so like I think that will
happen but it will when it does happen
it will only be a sign of your success
because now we've reached the point
where everyone here's Troy Baker
everyone here's nolan north and it's not
because they're doing the same voice
it's because they're so prolific yeah
you know so if you do reach a situation
where you're like everyone's just his
error it's because you're very prolific
which I imagine is ideally what you want
so yes that's a good problem to have
yeah I really can't imagine it Wow yes
so we monitoring the tattoo if you have
questions please put them in there we've
got a great one from Daniel Moreno what
are the variations of Eric's voice were
you considering for her character or was
that breathy one just the one that kind
of came to you um yeah so excuse me so
um the the breathy quality was not the
first thing I stumbled upon you know
when you listen to her other voice
actors you think you know she honestly
sounds like a like a Disney Princess
like she's clear as well and um you know
there's a there's a sharpness or a like
like hitting a wineglass kind of quality
to Disney Princess voices Aerith does
have if you listen to Maya Sakamoto her
Japanese voice actress she does have a
little bit more of like a like a breathy
almost like ethereal quality to her
voice that just gives it a little bit
more texture it's not so crystal clear
and so I I went a little bit more Disney
Princess at first as I was working
through okay I'm gonna go into this
audition how am I going to do this at
all because I had no experience with
voiceover auditions and the breathy
quality just made her sound a little bit
more um lovable I feel like oh I kind of
have went with that instead yeah I think
to to kind of like what I liked about
your performance of Eros and as someone
who has you know played all the other
Final Fantasy games and heard different
versions of it I think the one that made
it stand out you're the reason your one
standout stood out because it sounded
almost like different to everyone else
is kind of way they spoke and the way
they almost delivered the lines how it
sounded my ears and it made a lot of
sense that it was like that like her
voice was like it stood out amongst
everyone else and that made a lot of
sense to me because obviously she as a
character is very special she's not
human she's she's etc and she's got like
she's in touch with the world around her
in a way that no other character is yeah
so that kind of like elevated kind of
sound to her where it sounds like almost
like voice of God ish it's it's hitting
your ears in a different way
that's what to me yeah it's got a
texture that no one else had which is
why I love your performance of it so
much thank you I actually really love
Britt Behrens voice for the same reason
yeah it has that sort of texture to it
but in her version it's much warmer and
very much suits
Tifa it's it's really really awesome
yeah with with Britt's performance it's
that I mentioned I reviewed the game and
I mentioned it and it was like the
ability for her and it's a lot carried
elaborate performances like the ability
to allude to a history without having to
explain it it's really there in her
voice you can see that they care about
each other but they don't like the
history is coming through the way she
kind of like speaks to him instead of
like hey when you grew up together and
we you know might have had a budding
romance it's like you can just hear it
in the way she likes speaks
absolutely and that is both a testament
to just naturally how her voices but
also just how talented she is I mean
having replayed the game the first eight
hours of the game just last night I can
tell you just the amount of emotion that
she can put into one word oh and you
know what she's thinking I mean that's
amazing so we appreciate from the chat
that might leap on from that quite
nicely and trap MNT says ff7 remake is
obviously very anime influenced and
there a ton of anime gasps and grunts in
the game
those aren't obviously very common in
spoken English was it weird awkward or
difficult to record those because I
think is well you have to get so much
like meaning across in just those noises
- yes I would say that it was very fun
because you know in in a lot of the
recording that we did we would reference
what the Japanese version was and so
sometimes it would be something that
does not come across in English at all
so the sound that is made when someone's
in pain is completely different I think
it's like it sounds almost like they're
hitting the T sound over and over like
titute but that's not in English how we
say things were like ooh ow like ouch
that really hurt right so totally
different so those types of things the
writers would adjust and then they'd
come to us and tell us okay we need you
to adjust it in this way um but other
stuff like you know the hot uh yeah
things like that they were just kind of
fun to play around and try different
versions and sometimes you know they'd
be like you know what I don't I don't
know what direction to give you just
just throw something out so you throw
something out the first thing that comes
out of your mouth and you're like well
that was awful that was terrible we'll
never use that but it gives us a good
laugh anyway so I would say that part of
it was almost the most fun for me my
favorite line is in combat where you say
I'll show you what I can do like I use
that I use that line constantly myself
now
just even even the smallest task comes
they can't be bothered to make dinner
but then I'll just be like I'll show you
what I can do that makes me so happy
yeah it's it's the little things like
that that really hit me like what it
means to be in a video game like this
it's moments when I hear that people are
like hearing my voice lines in their
head throughout their day
what yeah alright it's my lucky really
amazing ok so we have a yeah go for it
while you're doing that I'll read out a
few donations we have we're gonna start
off with a donation that came in late
yesterday we had the last podcast on the
left's maka spots on the screen playing
Dark Souls and he pledged to donate for
the amount of deaths he had and he
donated $100 which was more than he
needed tuber thank you so much for
Marcus and I believe he did it for both
black lives and also for kovat relief so
great and then we had $25 for Jesse
parent cause black 11 Jeff DeLeon $25
we're already off to an amazing start
Kenneth Tiger ook $25 black lives matter
David Geiger $100 to black lives matter
Joanie those names yeah they seem like
yo crew Kelvin showing $20 Jason de
Xiang $10 for black lives matter and
then on the comedy relief side we've got
$25 from Lucy James yeah yeah then we
have in a hundred dollar donation I
believe that some Marcus and then David
Geiger again with $200 for call good
relief and he said I appreciate the play
for charity have fun thank you so much
David
we've got $50 from unfinished Stanley
the name is cut off I don't know what
Anton there we go that's one of your
viewers because it's always unfinished
Suntech because that's the joke it's
unfinished you get it yeah nice and then
last one from flop mana and other
strange rebel supporting the strange
rebel
thank you so much everyone donation
links are on the screen as Briana can be
playing and they're also in the
description to surprise you know a guest
last playthrough I didn't react with Mya
tier materia based on the next I don't
let I'd be into so I totally went in
with thunder materia on in my last
playthrough - and apparently I did not
learn my lesson so I my materia is
completely useless cool could you could
you could quit out and try again I I
don't have to go back to the air Buster
fight right oh no I could yeah I don't
like to think that's what you're
thinking right at the churched yeah so
you could I could from my playthrough
last night oh I was gonna say have you
been picking up more tips no I kinda
yeah I actually have been using punisher
mode 0 in my current playthrough on my
channel because i didn't really
understand the benefit of moving slowly
for a little extra power but that and
because i hadn't really been guarding
much at all
so I've completely relearned that system
yeah I think I found Punisher mode
sort of by accident obviously the game
tells you hey you know this is how can
you want to punish mode and I started to
do it and I was like oh so I mean we've
been going for 20 minutes and I think
it's worth shouting out the community or
community who has come and joined us for
this it's amazing to see everyone's
really positive in the chat and they're
being very warm and this life is coming
in an alarming rate so hello to everyone
from spree on his community
thank you welcome gamespot folks be nice
play well together it's always it's like
that moment where you're like two
parents introducing kill each other I
feel like I hope they like each other if
it looks weird on stream that I'm
looking all the way up here it's because
Sabrina you were saying that you had to
set up all your camera stuff just before
they started I managed to get my PC from
the office yesterday oh my god exact
same thing but I haven't set up my
eyeline properly so it looks like I'm
gazing off into the middle distance that
really does dismal I would feed for me
yeah my camera is here but my screen is
here so I'm not like bored looking over
there and just looking at donations on
another screen yeah someone in the chat
said you could technically rethought
that over it looks like you're doing
pretty well here this is this is the bit
perfect stop it
gonna try not to direct any questions so
I have a game prepared for Lucy
specifically which will allow Briana
focus on the game itself and fight and
so the game is final fantasy series
known for many things one of them being
summons guardians bosses espers aond
whatever you want to call them and
usually monsters that have strange names
so I'm gonna name a monster and you're
gonna tell me what whether it's from
Final Fantasy or not okay for every one
you get right I'm gonna donate $1 to
towards one of the causes either black
lives matter or covetous all right a
chat chat feel free to jump in as well
if you want and suggest some basically
something okay yeah thank you so I'm
gonna start with an easy one okay it
fritz Oh finally
big fire is correct that's a dollar I
have to get right if I get them wrong I
don't know
yeah yeah okay and so I'm at $1 you're
at zero I'm gonna do maybe like a couple
at a time so I also match oh if you want
it I do
okay so how do you want to how do we
want to do this then if there's three
people involved match um however many
Lucy anything you're gonna be good at
this because I was kind of so you can
match whatever Lucy gets right so you're
talking here I'll match whichever ones
higher how about that
okay okay that's amazing thank you so
much
all right so I'll do another one
dreadnought is it a final fantasy summer
or not you are correct it is not is a
Magic the Gathering creature if the
stream if my program feed had frozen or
if you were just really threatening out
so you got that one right
which means I don't say yeah I'll bring
I'll periodically drop those in I did it
no materia that was useful at all see
this is a Punisher mode because I
learned it last night sign of growth
you're becoming better I am you don't
any of any of the challenges like the
have you been doing the arena coming to
the VR from Chadli yes the only ones
I've unlocked so far are Shiva and fat
chocobo and I had a really easy time
with Shiva I had a harder time with fat
chocobo um but I did defeat it okay I'm
not gonna spoil whatever comes next so
but yeah if those could continue to be
fun
I'm really excited Oh question from Tim
long and the chat says uh speaking of
Disney Princesses that do you think Eric
would get along well with words who do
you think which Disney princess do you
think would be heiress besties okay hold
on I got to think about that one so so
her thing is definitely spunk and
pendants so I'm almost thinking that she
would be like BFFs with jasmine because
also the quicker yeah she does give off
a lot of jasmine vibes like that
headstrong kind of quirky
very energetic 5k yeah see her and
Jasmine getting up to no good in like
Agrabah totally and just like climbing
over rooftops obviously and like you
know trying to trying to feed the poor I
mean I think it's just they would like
handout apples and flowers together
right don't you
yeah I think you're and she's always
giving Aladdin grief and poking at him
in the same way that Arif does with
cloud yeah I have like a kind of
reflective relationship my in my head I
mean she I immediate you into Aurora
because of all the nature and like you
but then I think you're right I think
jasmine
I mean Aurora's other name is Briar Rose
so yeah interesting all right so I'm
gonna read a few donations because they
are coming in thick and fast and I don't
want to lose them so we've got fifty
dollars from Dennis they know thanks for
doing this hi Bri hi kento beans ten
dollars this is all for a kool bit
relief efforts Alex
Alexson and hellicksen guys I think Oh
Alexander Kaiser that that makes sense
yes I am able to read no and then I know
usernames that's for sure
good five dollars part of the strange
rebel hope everyone gets well amazing
antenna $77.77 and the message alongside
it is waffles SAR G that's how they roll
me we have this argument about which is
the superior breakfast bread so now I
pose that question to you both which is
superior breakfast bread so why the
options have waffles or waffles pancakes
french toast and slightly to the side
cinnamon rolls yeah I would say cinnamon
rolls are bread
adjacent they are their breakfast
adjacent they're not classic breakfast
but they're all the same ingredients
though yeah I'm gonna be I think I'll
probably I have to go with cinnamon
rolls because I love cinnamon
I always put cinnamon in my tea so
a little big cinnamon person yeah um I
always make like I'm Pakistani style
like masala tea which means after / like
cinnamon cardamom and like different
chilies and spices and that kind of
stuff and I'm a cinnamon boy I would say
french toast but I also put cinnamon on
it and Aunt Sarah yeah it's basically I
feel like french toast is the best of
all worlds okay thanks
syrup and cinnamon okay but the question
now Falls which is the worst breakfast
bread her me is really clearly waffles
because I don't love the pocket
distribution format no I don't mind a
big pocket a syrup but when I get a big
pocket of butter
oh yeah mate
at the start of lockdown went on a
mission to perfect waffles and she got
very very close she had these sourdough
waffles of white which were excellent in
a minute yeah that was that was the
game-changer they were very good I bet I
also agree with you about the
distribution of syrup suppose so so if
you're in the chat right now don't be
too mad waffles are the worst breakfast
bread it's been decided it's decided so
and we've got a donation from djk d or e
e JK tray DJ cadre one of those i could
be close hundred dollars towards kovat
relief thank you so much and the message
long said it was press square to win
Brian Mauck gave $10 moose six three
four gave seven dollars and said strange
rebel support coming in strong
absolutely Brian this is correct on that
and force on nine gave $10 and said hey
Bri soft oh thanks f Sam that's always
your message to me that rakul he's
playing a very cool
Joshua Franklin $20 donating for the
cause love you for doing this
and breeze awesome $50 from Budokan
muffin 87.7 seven cents for chair huh
yeah 777 renegade 77
there you go more seven donated seven
dollars off was number one breakfast
bread careful now just to argue but if
you were going to it would still be
appreciated yeah games
it's like saying the worst Spice Girl I
mean they're all pretty great and it's
an honor just to be nominated
[Laughter]
do you have a favorite Spice Girl no no
I honestly missed the Spice Girl thing I
never had a spice girl or NSYNC member
or a Backstreet member or Britney or
Christine I missed that whole I was
never my family we played video games so
we didn't pop culture like a ton of TV
we didn't listen to the radio very often
we would listen to like Alanis
Morissette together on CD yes my family
was a little unorthodox but I like to
think I got a very good culturing anyway
yeah we're coming to one of the most the
coolest parts of this game so I want to
I want to rattle off a few more
donations before we get there and I
start talking and we start having to you
about it Kevin dreschoff $25 to
blacklivesmatter Sean sprinkle $50
Tanika Dube $100 or in Hamilton $25 Kent
McCarthy $10 Craig Averell $50
John Dean Ruiz $25 Sebastian Sotelo $15
Jules
aghhhhhh $25 Bren
Brian Brian Brian McDonald $25
Andrew drop $25
that's a lot of donations thank you so
much oh you're all amazing I appreciate
it you thank you so this scene I was
reviewing the game and they seemed
literally overwhelmed to me like I had
to step away just cuz of their how
there's a line in my review where it's
like you fall in love with the
characters and it was this moment where
I was like I cannot believe how much I
fallen for these characters I think
everyone can agree with it like the
performance from cloud how reserve that
were reserved it was and then the effort
that your voice and your character was
putting in to kind of chip away at him
and turn this rough stone into something
smooth like playing through this moment
this is where I think this is where my
brain went I think this might be a 10
out of 10
like can you talk about a bit about the
process of how you kind of recorded this
bit and how was it doing this bit for
yourself
so we recorded this bit actually pretty
early on in the process and I think
because of that I didn't realize the
importance of it at the time I didn't
have the context of what everything else
that happens and they don't give you the
full script so I didn't get the chance
to see how important these beats were
and what what I really relied on was the
direction from the director and the
writers and they did just a phenomenal
job in my opinion of piecing it together
with with exactly the right rhythm in a
way that that does have that sort of
it's it's nostalgic but also novel both
at the same time it's playful but it's
also wistful in a way so in all of those
things I think I have to give a lot of
credit to the writers and directors for
making this moment just so impactful for
so many people
I really didn't when recording expect
this scene to be the standout hmm I mean
it definitely is and I think it is that
kind of wistfulness this is where it
like as well as what I said
or this is where also I realize how much
Final Fantasy 7 meant to me like really
because it had been a while since I
played it and I saw is a game that it's
kind of weird because it's one of those
games that so legendary and so beloved
that by default you think most people
care about it and when they're like oh I
love Final Fantasy 7 your kind of
responses yeah I mean who doesn't like
everyone loves Final Fantasy 7 and
select you kind of the feelings you have
for a goal in a lot of ways over the
years and then one of the amazing things
that this game does it really kind of
sharpens it and polishes that fandom and
this scene is specifically I was like I
had no idea how much I still care about
these characters and how much I still
care about like this game in this world
and it was the the banter and they're
kind of warm dynamic between these two
characters and how well it was delivered
and executed that kind of sparked that
again the way she liked everything your
voice is kind of like your performance
is kind of poking at his his ego and his
what he believes of himself you know
joking with him oh I thought this is
what soldiers were like and maybe I can
be a soldier and that kind of stuff yeah
the process of tearing him down to build
him back up is so expertly done here and
yeah I just I just love this scene so
much which is why I'm so glad that you
are able to play with us of course I
mean one of the things that that I think
is really core to aerith's character is
she has no ego and she doesn't she
doesn't care for ego in anyone she
doesn't see it
she doesn't value it and so you know
when cloud is being all Moody and
protective and well I'm a soldier and
I'm above bodyguard work era tha's like
okay and that's even echoed in the very
first scene in the game that they have
together where he says I'm involved in
things dangerous things and she goes oh
I'm sure you are
so yeah into her yeah it's so good and
like obviously I always ship a cloud
with tpho because they have their
relationship and also anyone who knows
the game knows that era
Zach but in this moment I was like they
should be together they need to be
together and I against my own judgment
and my own normal like it stances I'm
like this is they have to actually my
favorite passageway of the scene there's
something about how it's enclosed but
light just peeks through and it's kind
of overgrown here and it's not it's not
as like metal this is like one of the
areas where nature used to thrive before
it just couldn't anymore
right and I love this little passageway
interestingly enough as you mentioned
you know who do you ship I was playing
last night and in all of the cloud and
Tifa scenes I'm like oh yeah they should
definitely be together and then in all
of the cloud Aerith scenes I'm like yes
they should definitely be together I
think that's just a testament to how
well these scenes are written in that in
every single scene the characters
connect so well and it's so well written
that you just you believe that this is
the only thing that matters in that
moment in every I mean that's something
truly truly amazing and unexpected yeah
for sure there's there's a scene later
on which I won't go into too much detail
on in case that you haven't or some of
your audience hasn't seen it but like
you have to make a choice between
helping someone or either cloud or tiara
34 and the first time I did it I
immediately went for Tifa and then as
soon as I hit the bar now and know by
the way like one of the many reasons I
have played three played this game
multiple times is because a certain
points in this game it asks you to make
a choice between Aerith and and Tifa and
I hate that so much that ia was like the
only way I'm gonna get over this is if I
play it multiple times and do it every
single version so I've now done every
dress every decision-making moment
between them because I was like I need
to I need to make peace with this oh I
love that that makes me so happy but
which playthrough is your true play
through the first one my true
playthrough is the first one where
cloud and cloud expresses all his love
for 40 fur and I do that knowing that
Arif Aerith has a pre-existing romance
with someone and and you know as a final
fantasy 7 ya later knows I know but it's
the only way I can do it here totally
unlikely it makes it harder when I can
be like I said earlier that the writing
is so well that even knowing it I'm like
what if but she the way she kind of like
she you can feel like in the performance
that the the relationship of zach is a
part of her past that she kind of sadly
but also wistfully thinks about twitch
the way it's delivered makes it also
seem like she's ready to move on and
maybe cloud is that person to move on
with which is like oh man you're making
it hard for me it's hard it's written
that way I think yeah exactly it's
rigged
go ahead chat go mad cuz you did the
thing oh of course I need it as she did
the thing emote I always say that and
but 10:10 says why not Tifa and Eris I
mean that's a great one that that is
also it's 100% valid because there are
various scenes where they just like all
together and you're like this is all so
amazing like they clearly are like super
close and would get on like a house on
fire yeah I mean that's that's maybe
that's the official ship Arif antifa
like I said it's written so that every
single scene the characters connect as
much as possible to the point where it
just almost jumps off the screen at you
how much there is between each character
at any given moment that's pretty rare
in video games they really are
so we're in a pray beautiful scene and
it's amazing that it's beautiful
considering it's just here's a bunch of
like garbage piled on top of each other
each other it's wild
I think the reason I loved this because
I transparency I never played Final
Fantasy 7 before I never had it as a kid
but I knew of it and it's always kind of
been my you know the top of my I need to
get round to this and play this one day
and so when remake was announced I was
like I'm just gonna wait for remake and
so I loved low loads of other facets of
Final Fantasy like the music I've been
to Final Fantasy concerts before and yet
I've never played seven and so when
remake came out I kind of immediately
fell in love with it because the combat
is so much fun and so different those
like characters and these moments where
you have all the combat you know you're
taking out macro reactors and then you
know everything is like there's timers
that bombs is running away there's
things exploding and then you just have
these moments of rest bite and it's just
these really strong character moments in
just like I love a game that has the
confidence to give the player like just
to remove everything and just let the
player enjoy an emotional beat yeah this
scene does so brilliantly and this was
the standout for me I think I texted
town when I played it I was like oh my
god along the rooftops and the music is
going and I think I might cry yeah
the music is a big part of it of why
this scene is so impactful
I wrote my review too while listening to
snippets of the soundtrack that made
their way to YouTube and like it it was
the only way that I felt like I could
properly get the emotional kind of
response down in words by listening to
it and the reason that worked is because
like as for as long as the songs the
songs were playing from the game I felt
like I was playing the game and like
that helped me really get my words out
of it usually it's a struggle to make it
count and get it on you know make make
what your feelings are working on a page
but it was surprisingly easy for this
and
I started off by writing like 2,000
words and then completely scrapping it
because I was like it just doesn't
convey how I feel good enough and I
think I wrote for like 15 hours straight
and eventually got it out but like the
crucial point of it was listening to the
music that music is so powerful yeah it
really is I mean I think Lucy you really
hit the nail on the head when you said
that the game has confidence it's
moments you know it it it allows
complexity and that's really beautiful I
think that's what makes this game so the
combination of nostalgia and novelty and
then the dichotomy of well it's a
character-driven piece well it's an
action driven piece but the combat is so
good I mean all of those things kind of
in one the game does them all
brilliantly and when you play it you
almost feel like it's a part of you it's
so weird how it does that but it's it
does it sneaks its way into your heart
all right we're gonna we're going to
read some donations out well Briana
carries on this beautiful journey and
we've got $20 from Dennis $25 from
Dennis Chen and $20 from Joshua Franklin
and I think Jesse parent might have done
another $100 in a donation which is wild
and then $100 or towards black lives
matter from cash and flash a thank you
then Michael Leonean $20 Matthew Cole
$100 Nicholas Prasad 250 dollars antenna
antenna $77.77 the magic number
Tony MA $25 this is a great deal of the
strange rebel community coming in and
just absolutely killing it here so thank
you to everyone from there we've got $10
from the wilds Iqbal who is the gamespot
friend towards kovat relief and has
donated a bunch of times a hundred
dollars from maistro' who says go Bri
rebel hype
thank you so much and tzimmes aaj $20
with the question the source question
mark who knows no such missiles
unfinished sentence sent it came back
with another $50 donation saying this is
from everyone in their strange revel
community who is unable to donate Oh is
just absolutely beautiful
fifty dollars from Outlook who says love
you Bree the way you brought to life the
voice acting is very impressive also
mashed potatoes
a community a lot yeah good potatoes an
s-rank food drum j8o drum jate seven
dollars and seventy seven cents just
tell me that I made the difference you
did make a difference solid script a
hundred dollars here's the rest of my
charity budget for this year much love
to the crew from the strange web of
gaming fan community there you go such a
powerful presence from your community
here yeah they're there
I talk a lot about how the strange rebel
community is is powerful in its in its
community feeling and that all you know
working towards something together but I
also talk about the idea that there's an
individual responsibility that we all
have a responsibility to go forward and
and and move through life with the srg
spirit of breaking a tiss quo in all of
the right ways and i just think that my
community does that really really well
that it really does yeah they're doing
something but also we're made of
individuals and just I just really love
my people yeah I mean I watch the stream
there's a lurker mostly like having your
own waddle you know work is happening
and that kind of stuff and it's whenever
I look at the chat it's just like
positive and everyone's really warm and
enjoying what's happening and the stuff
you said about you know having an
individual kind of impact is just
exactly what we
you need right now and it kind of fits
perfectly with what we're trying to do
with our charity kind of stream you know
we don't raising money for black lives
matter you can see the links on the
screen as well as Colvin relief and the
whole point of it is you know everyone
can make a difference whether that's
with a dollar or whether that's just
raising awareness or whether they're
just speaking to people and sharing
links so to have a community as already
engaged in doing that as yours
join us on stream and have you on stream
to play and talk about your experiences
incredibly complimentary I think I'm
really happy to be here I mean honestly
this is the first charity stream I've
done this year so I it was really
important to me thank you so much and we
get to play an awesome game exactly I
feel kind of weird because like I said
I'm playing through on my channel we're
on chapter 14 right now but now I have
this second playthrough that I'm also
obsessed with I'm like is my whole life
just gonna be remade content someone did
ask earlier in the chat are there any
other games that you want to play in
stream after final fantasy yes The Last
of Us - oh my gosh there you go Oh two
days away
I always people that I wait a few weeks
but when a game comes out because I like
them to play through it themselves first
and then they can join me live but this
was really hard for me because I I've
already been a little bit spoiled I
don't want to get even more spoiled but
oh my gosh and I dunno man that game is
designed to be bleak unrelentingly bleak
and that's kind of the point but I think
you're gonna need some of that Aerith
levity to to kind of get through that
one so yeah you'll be using that a lot
no Ted okay here we go so while you do
this combat I'm gonna drop into our game
again Lucy you ready oh is this a Final
Fantasy summon or is it something else
okay ready yeah Darumaka could you spell
it please the a our um aka NSA final
fantasy that is incorrectly sir that is
a Pokemon generation is number 554 in
the pokédex I don't know what generation
this is it looks like generation 515 is
a fire pokemon the room occur is evolves
into doorman doorman Nitin I never say
five ice-type regional forum do to be
fair it's terrifying I didn't even
realize we were a 500 when I came to
Pokemon that's how yeah we are way
beyond 500 my friend oh wait yes I think
that I think it's in like the eight
hundreds at this point I reckon oh yeah
we all way way past quick yes in her
making Pokemon outta lamps and stuff
yeah yeah I mean they do have some of
those but then they have some amazing
ones there's like I thought I I'm at a
stage where I just find a couple of
Pokemon that look interesting to me and
just remember them so like the most
recent one is hawlucha which is a
luchador bird that I really love so yeah
and other than that it's Ganga I like
Ganga hawlucha that's pretty much it
when two more moved over to the states
we got him how would you describe it
it's it's it's like it's this just
really I'm gonna say this in the most
loving way possible because it's
designed to be this way
this really garish bit of bling like
it's Ganga purple but like it's shining
with gems
oh yeah is is wild is it's beautiful I'm
kind of annoyed that it's still in my
desk at work otherwise I would have
liked warning on some of these trees
what do you have a favorite Pokemon
Briana I would have back in the day but
I I'm dealing with Pokemon overwhelm
ever since so many of them in so many
iteration so I haven't played any of the
more recent games I know they're good
but now I am in a place where I'm very
much living the TMG life and in srg well
if you watch my streams you know what
TMG is but it's basically there's just
too many games I can't possibly play
them all I would love to I know they're
good I just cannot possibly play them
all and Pokemon is one of those ones I
just can't fit into my schedule so I
would love to play it it's just not not
there right now did you get into Pokemon
go when that was you know 20 2016 yes I
did quite a bit a group of my friends
and I would go out walking but you know
it just didn't scale fast enough for me
and so I I it fell off for me and died
out when they introduced raids yeah so
I'm not I did come on its raids but when
they introduced raids this just kind of
when the hype died down and I it was
just it was that classic um mobile game
issue where the first you know hours
that you play are so addictive and so
fun and then it's designed to get harder
and harder to encourage you to spend
more and more money yeah yeah three very
averse to microtransactions I don't have
a problem with them being out there
I just don't personally like to spend
money on that kind of stuff
so personally that's kind of when I
bowed out that's fine yeah I think it's
what the same I played it for a bit I
lived in here know the office was right
next to a polka stop so you just leave
fines open all day but then I
fell off it yeah quickly tonight here's
the question if
Aerith had a Pokemon what do you think
it would be I guess um if we're gonna
keep talking about red today I guess I
mean growlithe would be the most similar
Oh see I was thinking very so yeah see
for me it's like I'm going with the pink
angle cuz she loves she's got that dress
and so like a Clefairy next to her or
maybe a clefable like I think like they
would match up really well but I also
kind of feel like she would want
something very unexpected like she'd
throw a Pokeball and a ghost Pokemon
would appear and she'd just be like yeah
ghost cool I mean based on the game
there's there's some evidence for that
else I personally think if we're going
to put for aesthetic the best fit is
probably Clefairy of clefable but I
think in personality she's a Haunter
girl where she throws it out the horse
comes out immediately licks whatever's
in front and she's just like yes good
totally yeah I totally a lot of people
in charge same Jigglypuff Jigglypuff
yeah a lot of people are talking
Jigglypuff that's a great as Jigglypuff
you know wants attention and if you
don't give it to her in her way she's
immediately gonna be upset and draw all
over your face that's pretty eros that
is very earth energy yeah we've got a
few more donations $25 from chelsea dry
and then seven dollars and seventy seven
cents from Jaime white and the stores
black lives matter and then we've got
twenty dollars from Hanuman and
subcaptain
seven dollars and seventy seven cents
sevens all around smiley face the
perfect number yeah and then the Nick
Prasad two hundred and fifty dollars
nick says hi Branagh
go strange rebel oh go strange rubbles a
strange reference
fantastic so I guess the question that a
lot of your audience will have already
heard the answer to um but some of the
folks done maybe on the GameSpot side or
the general public at large there
she may not know is how did you even get
this shot and how did you end up in one
of the most beloved games of all time to
remake for one of the most beloved games
of all time did you know it was gonna be
Final Fantasy when you took the audition
let's say this job fell out of the sky
and hit me on the head I really have no
idea how I got here I don't have a
voiceover agent or demo
I didn't submit myself I wasn't even
submitted for this the casting director
found me on IMDB is what I was told had
nothing to do with the fact that I play
video games on YouTube or anything like
that um so it really just kind of felt
like fate truly um which and I'm a
believer in fate but I I'm also a
believer and you know you have to work
hard and position yourself correctly and
you know right place right time but also
I did nothing right to get this to get
this audition let alone get this role um
so I don't know how I got I really don't
um it feels like fate and um I'm just
very fortunate I'm very happy and gratit
grateful honestly I really don't have
anything more intelligence god I know
gonna be this big of a deal yes I did
know what I was auditioning for I knew
the character and I was able to do some
research beforehand I knew how excited
people were for it I think whether you
kind of work to get it or not I think
the important thing is a lot of people
would agree like you did a great job
with it
so yeah I think I think there's a lot of
you know people a lot of stock on who
should be a thing and you know whenever
someone's like oh who would play this
character it's always some famous name
is gets thrown into it but if anything
your story is an indication that it
doesn't have to be a named super you
know famous person it's just someone
cares and it willing to put in the work
to make it memorable which is what
you've done here and I think did a lot
of really hard work I put every ounce of
my heart and soul into the work and part
of that is because I I knew I was coming
in as a rookie I knew I didn't have a
ton of experience to draw from as far as
voice specifically so I mean I went to
teachers I was researching what felt
like every single night you know online
for resources for how do you solve this
problem or how do you do this right and
a lot of the technical stuff was
extremely challenging for me having
never done it
I knew the basic basics like speak into
the microphone instead of speaking here
but for those of you who don't know
sometimes you do actually have to speak
off mic if the mic is a little bit windy
even though you have a pop filter so I
mean just it's it's so technically
challenging I definitely put in the work
once I booked the role mmm but as far as
you know what did I do to get the
audition right place right time I don't
know where it is a big believer in fate
and destiny so yeah it's yes she is I I
know there's for everything mmm what's
the biggest difference between like just
voice acting and acting just right you
kind of mentioned you know having to
take into account mic mic and stuff
there but what else kind of did you do
in a performance capture for it or was
it just voice it was just voice and um
oh boy you know I have been expecting
because I I know later on in the
playthrough this is like a really
challenging battle area so I was like
witness something gonna come popping out
at me and it did um so what's the
difference between acting and voice
acting I would say that with acting you
get all your tools you can express with
your eyes you can express with your
hands so if it's not all coming through
in one part of your body it's coming
through in another
but invoice and you only get one tool
yeah so it has to be like very
concentrated ly correct if it's not
coming through
you have to listen back to yourself so I
know a lot of actors will say oh I don't
watch my my playback I don't watch
myself cuz whatever reason I get in my
head or it makes me nervous
umm I'm not like that I think that you
can only grow by watching yourself and
in fact you have to because if
something's not coming through on screen
you have to know what it is but you also
have to be able to look at yourself
objectively which is another skill in
and of itself I would say a lot of the
skills between acting and voice acting
do translate but in voice acting
everything is just very very
concentrated on one single skill that
you have yeah question from the chat is
did you have any kind of visual aids
from Alex RN do you have any cutscenes
or any visual aid when recording or was
it just a script and you know you're
like a director in your PA we did have
visual aids occasionally I can't say too
much about it but usually when I get
asked questions about the details like
that I try to say that we got everything
that we needed to make sure that the
performance was what it needed to be
whether that was picture visual aids or
whether it was you know having a really
long conversation beforehand about what
the scene means in the larger context of
the game whatever we needed we got it
did you I mean obviously you mentioned
speaking to Britta Bundchen and various
other folks that have Erica you
mentioned I think earlier and did you
spend a lot of time with the rest of the
cast like you know the voice of Barrett
for example John Eric Bentley for
example what are they like to hang out
with what was the process like for them
and how were you kind of working with
them we recorded individually so I
didn't get to do actual scenes with the
other voice actors and there's a lot of
reasons for that but mostly it's just a
very technically
challenging process um so I met all the
other voice actors at various
promotional events like III 2019 at the
square Enix press conference I got to
meet John Bentley and Erica Lynn Beck
and Cody Christian and um let's see I
met Brent for the first time at PAX East
this year oh my gosh I can o PAX East
was this year seriously I don't even
know what day it is anymore don't think
about the time now think about time oh
okay so PAX East was this year I met
Britt there I also met Gideon who voices
bigs and every everybody everybody is so
wonderful it's shocking because you know
as as when you're when you're working
you don't always like the people that
you're working with but every single
person that I met that was a part of
this team was amazing so kind generous
with their time and energy very
intelligent as far as whether they were
giving direction or whether they were
giving advice just very warm like John
Bentley and Eric Olympic are very warm
people very love kind of oozes out of
their pores and so I I just have had
such an amazing time being a part of a
group like that I want to spend all my
time with them I want to support all
their other work it's amazing it's very
family feeling for sure just a reminder
I mean it's on the screen just to call
it out we are raising money for black
lives matter and for covered relief
efforts as important trip with Direct
Relief you can see the links to donate
if you can bid Oly for / yes - BLM or GS
- co vid every penny goes straight to
those causes and every every dollar
amount helps if you can't donate that's
fine just share and of the stream or
just share the links or it doesn't have
to be our link just you know a black
lives matter or COBIT relief effort link
just raise awareness around those causes
and
yeah very good hot is I'm really glad
you're all doing this we've got a couple
of donations to read out Jamie white
7077 for black lives matter and then
this is a great name waffle dispenser
that user name before waffles were even
controversial in streaming so honestly
that's on them I feel I understand
completely but this waffle dispenser for
good or better West game $25 for black
lives matter so I'm on board with
waffles for a little we've got a man
Tory $20 to Ward's Cove aid relief says
hi Breanna sending my love to the best
English voice actress for Erath ever
oh sweet 77 $25 enjoying the stream and
props to Rihanna for playing through and
beating air Buster again for us to see
today yes
hashtag team bench is your energy yeah
seven dollars from rind wave and another
$30 from Affleck who says nothing
compared to you very wholesome yeah it's
very wholesome but also an inside joke
so yeah Lucy are you ready for another
challenge
oh no God is this a final fantasy
monster or have I made it up okay here
we go
let's see
Videl ken could you tell them II D a el
que e n is that a fan of fancy summon s
/ a on wherever you may call it or is it
from somewhere else you get it right you
donate a dollar if you go if you get it
right I donate a dollar if it get Ron
you don't hear dollar don't oh my god
that's the game that's the joke that's
I'm gonna say not cool you are correct
Oh Magic the Gathering monster so you
win I'm at $4 Wow I'm a 1/1 okay Oh
network what are your thoughts this is
from Chelsea Briana what are your
thoughts about the future of Erath as a
character going forward what do you wish
most for her character and story oh I
wish that she said every line in the
entire game and she was the main run a
fantasy character in every final fantasy
going forward uh-huh I mean they're
great fair enough as far as like what I
want for her character mmm I just want
her to have a good story whatever that
is
I want that for her because I think that
good stories whether they have well and
in all good stories I think have
triumphs and have sadness and have
obstacles to overcome and those
obstacles have to be difficult so that
when you overcome them it really means
something I want that for Eris I want
her to get a really really good
complicated story that speaks to people
that shares her hope and trust and faith
in a higher power with everyone in the
world I want people to feel better after
having known her story that's really all
I want agreed
yeah I was gonna say like it don't think
you beat that answer that is yeah and
like that that's part of the most
interesting that's that's part of the
potential that makes her character
interesting like she's this game has
established her as someone who's like
you basically have no choice but to fall
in love with her in various you know
different ways she's endearing and
charming but you also kind of know that
at some point she's gonna have to go
through some trials and tribulations all
very serious yeah and that's kind of
like one the hardest thing to grapple
with because you know that next game is
not gonna be a cakewalk for her I mean
she's had a she has a kind of difficult
time in this game but it's around
friends and people who she's learning to
love and know and putting herself out
there the next one it's grouped by its
very nature it's gotta be a bit of a
journey for her like you said that's
ideally what you want right both as
people who like the character and then
someone who's acting the character you
want that journey yeah would be the same
era that all the time and that's what
makes a story worth telling and that's
one of the things that they teach you in
every you know actors script analysis
class or every writing class is that any
story worth telling has a character that
is different for having gone through
what happens in that story so there's a
lot of moments in this game Aerith
moments I call them whether you know she
whether she's prodding and clouds ego or
just having a bit of a laugh do you have
a favorite one because for me and I know
for a lot of people it's the it's the
i-5 saga the arc of the high five it's
so good that moment do you have one that
you like is it that same one or is there
anything else some smaller that you're
like Thor gnostics that to me is
actually the smaller moment a smaller
Aerith moment I mean I think I could
definitely speak to the larger Aerith
moments being incredibly impactful
whether it's
the scene she has in woolmarket or the
scene she has at the very beginning of
chapter 14 without spoiling anything so
those are the very like big impactful
Aerith moments that are very close
favorites of mine and then as far as the
smaller moments I would say I love the
moment the high five moments are very
good I remember doing recording all I
could think about was I cannot wait for
everyone to see this it is so fun and
people are gonna love it so much
yeah I knew that and then the moment
where and me because it's just replayed
this but that or we just replayed this
part but the moment that really sticks
out to me is when Aerith is about to
jump off one of the rooftops and she has
this moment where she's like oh I got
this and then she like has to hype
herself up and she's like I don't know
if I got this this is really high up the
bird comes and throws her off but cloud
catches her right I love that moment I
loved the beginning middle and end of it
and then she totally teases him and then
is like my hero right yeah
everything about that moment is just
perfect for their characters and is
echoed multiple times throughout the
game and that moment when we were
recording really stuck out to me is like
people are gonna love this yeah yeah
it's kind of like that the moment where
she lets her guard down a bit yeah and
without actually kind of like giving too
much wave for cloud to you know give him
too much of an opportunity for him to be
like actually you're quite vulnerable
too I think in my favorite arias line I
think she's got it's two words and it's
the best comedic ly delivered line in
the game and maybe in a lot of games but
it's the local florist line and towards
the end of the game where they're all
saying who they are and she's like local
florist I was like that that made me
laugh so hard why and I loved it so much
I think that's my favorite line in the
game they're just a ragtag
of random bits and bobs coming here if
the world together
yeah Giulio Maldonado asks what was your
biggest challenge you've ever had when
you were acting for eros thank us for
anything I think for anything I think I
may be an heiress wanted maybe uh a
general one my because that's really
tough um
of all of the acting roles that I've
done I would say I definitely had the
least experience with voice acting and I
had sort of the most self doubt with
Aerith because I had never had such a
gap between my level of experience and
my trust and my capability and and how
important the role was so I'd never had
such a large gap in those two things you
know if I wasn't sure I could do it but
I just had a few lines I would have been
okay but because it was so important and
people were so passionate about this
character I felt a lot of pressure and I
also knew I had no idea what I was doing
and I had to learn really quickly
so I would say this is my biggest acting
challenge of all of the ones that I've
had because in all my other acting roles
I was taking things on that I knew I had
done before you know I've been acting
since I was 7 years old
it started in musical theater and then I
did over 30 student films with my time
at NYU and so when I started acting
professionally in LA I had that who kind
of give me confidence that I've been
here before I've done this a million
times
I can totally do this um but but who
aerith's was really I wanted to do it
right and that was really hard yeah
thank you you you're obviously a big
gamer if there we've asked a lot of
people this especially folks who are in
the voice-acting phase if there was any
other franchise that you could do a
voice for
what would it be oh I answered this one
all the time I would love to do a voice
in a Legend of Zelda franchise I love
this all the games they're my childhood
games that I would play with my mom so
the Zelda series is and there aren't a
ton of series of games well and that's
not even true even as I say it because
I'm like wait Dragon Age would be really
good wait Mass Effect would be really
good there's there's lots of series wait
which are like all of these things would
be awesome but I have a deep love for
Final Fantasy because I play a lot of
Final Fantasy 14 so to be a part of this
series was one of in the top three
already
but Zelda would really be very close
there yeah yeah awesome
our resident Final Fantasy 14 phone is
probably losing his mind right now
Oh I mean I've played at this point
probably 1,500 hours of the game our
resident Final Fantasy found Michael
home final formula and he's so into it
that he offers to pay for people
subscriptions so that he could get him
into it he's a madman I'm like I really
want to play Final Fantasy 14 but I'm
also kind of secretly scared of it
because I know that it will get its
hooks in me and that's kinda like what I
hear from everyone that it's so great
you know you push past that they're
releasing that patch to kind of
streamline things and so hmm there is
the part of me that just goes just try
it out when that patch goes now with you
yeah
now we're I'm yeah I played maybe 70
hours of it and then my character is now
stranded on a British I cannot access
because I'm an American l oh oh I'm I'm
waiting for it to be kind of updated so
I can start fresh yeah I'm gonna get
Michael home to pay for my subscriptions
yes service to transfer server is there
something like that right yeah I think
you can but I don't think unless you do
it for like across from UK to tears
America yeah that's really sorry
for my character takis Fuego so rest in
peace he's stuck in so he called yeah
his name is takis Fuego stand he looks
like one of those takis Fuego chips
he's like orange and red head and he's
an awful awful character but I love him
to death
couple more and we have one from Crimson
sin who says go strange rebel community
and the cause also Briana bench says hi
$20 bench does say high bench bench love
bench life this scene with everything
that Eric does with the kids I love
those kids are adorable and especially
like there's that that be and there's a
bit towards the end where Aerith and
Marlene meet and it is just the most
like heart meltingly beautiful kind of
interaction between this kid who's like
I think of her like as video games
version of boo from Monsters Inc because
yeah as far as a movie movie like
animated kids go no one tops boo boo is
adorable and now I think Marlene is the
video game version okay so like when
they come together and they hang out
it's just adorable but I love these kids
with their fake busts the swords running
around and causing mystic mischief I
think my favorite thing about it is that
Aerith is immediately so drawn to you
know helping children and and making
sure they have a good life in whatever
way possible
so she's really connected to her
community but cloud he's pretty clear
that he like does not like kids and he's
not the type either that would like kids
but through all of the adventures he has
with eros later on in the game any time
he interacts with a kid he is very
gentle with them yeah yeah I have really
sweet transformation he goes through
yeah without eros there would 100% not
be a discount untold King jobs at all so
I think it's it's she's she's the reason
why I tried it's a good lad kids love it
um Lucy are you ready for another oh
okay
final fantasy salmon or not have I given
you the name of a final fancy salmon or
have I given you the name of something
that is not a fancy summon let's go with
I just like to stop here and enjoy it
sometimes yeah yeah
I throw nice this area this is the part
where I was just hammering the screen
shot button on my gas station and I
really really hope they put photo mode
in just from my replay so because I'm
playing him horizon zero dawn again at
the moment I got inspired from watching
forbidden West trailer and I was like
I'm like really about an hour into the
game but it's taking me closer to three
because I keep stopping and photo moding
everything so and you should yeah it's
really beautiful game and so unlike
seven is as well there are so many shots
that have just framed so nice it was
like whoo I want that as a wallpaper oh
I want that for my XYZ but totally yeah
alright do blade blade D o ub l a de
deux blade is there a poke Pokemon is it
imagine covering card or is it a Final
Fantasy summon or is it something else
entirely
that sounds like a Pokemon sounds like a
Pokemon to me - oh let's also you said
is it a Pokemon if I ruined it
yeah yeah I drop drop myself in that one
that's me that's fine I'll add a dollar
to the donation five dollars okay
I'm gonna do another one stray off
actually I'll go next one okay
okay how is this a final fantasy summon
is it something else
incarnation incarnation yeah
just called incarnation that sounds like
a Magic the Gathering card is a magic
I'm just going by process of elimination
cuz it geez I mean it could have been
any of them I was thinking I don't
fantasy Simon yeah because it is kind of
vaguely Final Fantasy's summoner yeah
yeah you saw three all right I'm at six
dollars fantastic alright we've got any
more questions from the chat
well this he finds a question I'm just
gonna reiterate that we are raising
money for black lives matter and Kol vid
relief efforts you can see the two links
on the screen you can donate to either
you can donate both you can do that
using the link bit ly /gs - BLM for
black lives matter or GS - covert for Co
vid relief efforts and if you can please
donate generously and if you can't share
the links around just get people aware
of the cause and try and get them to
kind of spread it and raise awareness
around it I'm incredibly valuable and
necessary right now and shout out to the
huge strange rebel community who is in
the chat donating being call and just
hanging out
question from chat from mobs alley hi
Bree what is your favorite film and
video game other than ff7 remake cough
cold favorite film and video game mm-hmm
okay so my favorite movie is a little
bit surprising my favorite movie is
Cloudy with a Chance of Meatballs
oh it's so funny and sharp and
well-written there's a really good joke
every five seconds in that movie whether
it's a visual joke or it's in the script
or what-have-you it's just amazing and
I've watched it over 30 times at this
point and I just enjoy it more and more
every time as well as it has an amazing
cast of voice actor comedians like Bill
Hader on a ferris I mean the list goes
on amazing film super underrated
and everyone should watch it whether
it's the fact that it's a kids movie it
means nothing to how good it is exactly
and let's see um favorite video game
that one it's too hard I can't I can't I
don't
I mean Final Fantasy 7 remake is my
favorite video game of course it is of
course right but I mean besides that I I
love all video games I can't even say
like Final Fantasy 14 yeah I've put the
most hours into it but it's not my
favorite and then breath of the wild is
super super good but it's not my it's
just oh man it's like asking me to pick
a favorite food I like it all but that's
a very fair answer what are you four are
you talking about snack foods are you
talking about dinners are you talking
about breakfast breads exactly exactly I
think that's the I think that's the most
like street cred worthy answer like I
know I love all the games yep they're
all so different too yeah really one in
every flavor yes
Tim ah yes did you see the Cloudy with a
Chance of Meatballs sequel I did it's
also good it's a little bit it doesn't
have as much polish in my opinion it's a
little bit less of a classic story like
maybe it's a
bit too on-the-nose preachy sometimes
about like but we are friends and
friends are what matter
so sequels not as good but still still a
phenomenal film yeah I saw but I did
love the original and my niece's are a
huge a huge huge fans of it and so I
have very nice memories of watching it
with them how do you feel about your
mother your in-game mother Elmyra
Gainsborough oh she's an amazing amazing
character yes so when she came when she
first showed up and is incredibly stern
to cloud that's like man she's to relax
but then you see why why she is that way
and it comes like really really it
becomes a moment for her to kind of like
accept to you in a way so I always
wonder what people think about that
character I think that she's amazing in
the fact that she I feel that Aris you
know for all of the credit that she gets
because she's an ancient she loves to
plant it and she's flower girl all that
but she gets a lot of her desire to help
people from Elmira as Myra did the same
thing you know she saw someone in need
and she just made it happen you know
whatever it took and she is she's
consistently shown that level of you
know it's it's important to to care for
other people and to do for others and to
be selfless and so I think Aerith gets a
lot of her development from Elmira and
and that's not necessarily as credited
as some of the other features of Aaron I
love Elmira as a character yeah and what
mother wouldn't you know look at her
daughter bringing home a look at this
moody guy I mean come on
look at him he's got an eight foot
scored on his back her being a knife
he's right my mom would give a slipper
on sight say leave and never come back
yeah take your giant knife and gal of
hair outta here and also how do you
style your hair like that it is defying
gravity it sure does
it's cool too you know and he moves
around it still shakes in the breeze and
you're like how does it stick up and
also shake in the breeze it's only kinds
of hairspray in there young man
it's important how are you carrying that
sword with arms that small it's not
possible it's really not I would love to
see a version of the game where they
swap weapons and cloud it gives his
possible to eros and there with roles
worthy and and cloud has to use the
magical stuff that would be incredible I
just want to see Aerith where the pasta
sold basically I would you know really
fun like challenge mode mm-hmm yes like
that that would be really cool I can
imagine that really hard and not
impossible but it would be so cool
that's how this exists
yeah I feel like that's how this series
has the end like it's it's cloud the
clouds out everyone's out its Aerith
versus Sephiroth and to defeat him she
uses everyone's weapons she's got the
sword she's got the hand cannon she's
got every single weapon that everyone
has tifa's gloves on 1v1 versus f4 off
using every single weapon I can I can
see that yeah I can just imagine
square enix if you need me to write the
scene for you hit me more point zero
says clouds hairspray is doing more
environmental damage than Shinra like
seriously definitely this is I love this
area yeah I think I walked up and down
this area so many times it's really cool
yeah and then you see it again at night
and it's it's just incredible
I'm gonna read a couple of donations
we've got towards blacklivesmatter we've
got Anthony fagiani $25 our very own max
Blumenthal gave $25 thank you max max is
a huge
Final Fantasy 7
player he gets into combat in a way
that's quite alarming so he's done like
combo videos for us and that kind of
stuff so if anyone wants to see higher
level Final Fantasy 7 combat player you
can find that on our Channel and usually
max is playing yeah you should watch his
his breath of the wild stuff too like
max yes so good at breath well I think
he discovered he's one of the best in
the world yeah yeah he's like premier
better the world player and he's our
apex guy as well so using caraway
Max is probably the best game that we
have one of them yeah Ilya camera max
mapu buddy gave $25 towards black lives
matter and in Steven Lau 250 dollars
from Steven Lau it is unreal thank you
so much series yeah it's gonna go to a
really important cause and really help
out a lot of people that are in need so
thank you so much for putting your own
money hard-earned money behind it all
right we're hanging out picking flowers
last time all the three well so they let
you pick three different flowers and I
picked all of them as this yellow flower
because in my original playthrough I did
one of each and I think a lot of people
probably did that so I picked all three
as this yellow lily so that maybe I
don't really know how far in the game
you get before you see the results but
yeah I when I played for the first time
I did the exact same thing I picked the
three yellow lilies you did yeah mainly
because I was like I just like these
yellow lilies I did one of each - I just
wanted to have a little variety over ie
a bouquet I picked one of each because I
wanted to hear all of the voice lines
that she says when he selects the
different flowers yeah I remember
recording the line something it's like
it goes something like boo foxtails huh
that's me uh Homer I never would have
thought of that cuz they're not really a
flower they're not made to be pretty
she's kind of even poking fun at his
flower choice
I love this thing so good
Oh people on the chat are calling out
Bali weird
you're not serious we're job for me
today what about it yes so I and a
number of my friends produced a web
series entirely in quarantine that set
in quarantine we wanted to make a little
art while we were not working on other
projects and we wanted to make something
that hopefully could speak to everyone's
experience about what chaos coronavirus
has caused in our lives so yeah it
produced it was produced just a few
weeks ago and it airs today so it'll be
on YouTube which I'm really excited
about so everyone can go check that out
if they want awesome who else is in it
with you do you want to shout them out
so the the writers are my friends
Joshua Levy and prathiba son and prati
is also the main character actress in it
so um really really excited about it do
you I think one like as terrible
obviously is that kovat has been it's
kind of been incredible to see how
people have adapted to the situation and
working from home and doing creative
projects obviously there's been you know
whole shows are moving online and stuff
it's okay then people I don't know just
making the best of what is ultimately a
very strange and sad situation yeah um
is super interesting to see and to
experience how some days you go you know
this is actually helpful and and could
bring up a lot of really good
conversations you know it's given
everybody in society something common to
fight against so that we all you know
have this very like together mentality
right now which is obviously helping
other social causes because we're all we
all know we're in this together because
we're actually having the time to stop
working and you know get off the
grindstone and look around and say wait
a minute things have not been good and
sometimes you need
rest to be able to have that sort of
higher elevated thought and so there is
a lot of good that's coming out of this
absolutely insane crazy terrible
situation and I think that that sort of
mindset of wow this is really terrible
some people are really having a hard
time you know there are people dying
from this disease across the world but
we can't control that what can we
control how can we turn this for the
best and how can we have the best
mindset to move forward and I think that
that's something really important to
focus on when everything feels like
you're in the eye of a storm for sure
yeah well said kind of said it better
but while will do is Lucy are you ready
there we go I believe or is it something
else entirely okay brothers a tale of
two sons may be brothers yep wait that's
the whole name yep that's the whole name
I'm gonna say magic card that is not
correct
no a final fantasy 8 summon the brothers
are a pair of minor tours from it's my
favorite one too so it's a must play
it's great get on it
I know it's on my list my ever expanding
too many games Brianna says it too many
years TMG mg like I thought I was gonna
be able to finish persona 5 royal before
the Last of Us that is not the case it's
a very yeah only 40 hours into it and
it's roughly a hundred and say yeah you
got some work
we had a another donation just now from
the Nick Prasad who donated earlier
but his latest donation is $300 Wow next
says where's chairs kami Aubry
oh excuse me there's chair look Thank
You chair for being a part of the
charity stream yeah for all that you do
yeah support yeah that chair provides is
essential yeah yeah yeah some would say
that scream wouldn't be able to happen
without chair so we wouldn't hmm there
is Thank You via donation that is an
amazing amount of money do we have any
more questions everyone well it's now
we're arguing about ff8 hopefully if it
is skippable some people are saying it's
a favorite but also Mack says hip-hop
the Chocobo play it yes
Final Fantasy a is one of the best but
also the most capable which is a strange
dichotomy for a game to have but yeah
it's it's I love it because it's weird
there's a character who does an uppercut
and when he does it and dolphins appear
and just brush over him like it's Free
Willy like amazing he also runs around
the entire world to deliver a punch so
like zel is amazing it's also very like
it's like teen drama final fantasy era
because it's all about likes magic
schools and futuristic and stuff like
that and then one of them's got like a
an evil kind of slant to them and
there's a witch who's trying to take
over the world and it's fun I mean it's
a lot fun nice yeah get Final Fantasy 8
remake go in square enix
um cost briana Ezra Noah and we're good
love it was asking what your PC specs
are oh so I just built a new PC actually
I have the eye 9 9999 hundred the
given up on trying to stay up to date
with pcs at this point okay so it's yeah
it's my CPU is the Intel 9900 K
something like that and my GPU is Nvidia
2060 and I have the internal elgato
capture card I have let's see 16 gigs of
ram although my ram is from my old pc
because the new ram that I bought
wasn't working it was dead on arrival so
no power supply unit is the corsair 1300
platinum so really sorry not coursera
please excuse me that's not correct
it is the Coolermaster 1300 platinum
very exciting super more than I needed
but a really beautiful mini power supply
what else we got in there
oh my fan is the cooler master hyper -
one - black editions that's super
exciting very quiet works really well
this is the elite Aerith set up for
video gaming yes I wanted to make sure
that I could edit really quickly that I
could play video games at a super high
level before we make came out so I just
built this new PC in February and my
case is super beautiful as well it's the
it's a cooler master case I'm not sure
of the exact name of it but it's
beautiful and I have a PC set like new
build setup vlog that's actually going
to be going up on my youtube channel
soon so that you can make sure to check
out my youtube channel when that's up
I'm on the verge of buying a PC I keep
saying this I'm like on the very edge
and I keep like finding things to push
me ever closer it seemed like every day
someone's like I just caught in your PC
or I'm making a thing about a PC I'm
like literally yesterday wasn't yeah and
now making pcs and videos were and I'm
like damn I could do it everyone to be
fair it's not yeah I used to build it
all the time and then I was just like
the drama of it I don't like the stress
of it like oh it's very restful
yeah usually like it's fine there's
always something that will go wrong and
it's always something die easy to fix
like a wires just plugged in the wrong
place or something is screwing in better
or see it better but the stress of it is
just like the whole like don't
short-circuit anything so you have to
ground yourself yeah so very dramatic
yeah and I'm a hairy boy so I build up a
lot of stake and that scares me to no
end I need to like attach myself to
everything to make sure and it stresses
me out
but yeah I think I might buy one fairly
soon just because I miss having a PC
like you know it's one of those weird
things where I always I always like have
had a PC in my room to play games on and
write from and this is the first time
I've not had one and I've been it
doesn't feel like a home until a PC is
in there for me and I think I've
realized that recently home is where the
gaming PC is yeah playing video games on
PC longer than on consoles so I
understand yeah for sure
we have a massive donation from Steven
Lau two hundred and fifty dollars
towards covert relief efforts thank you
so much
Steven says love this play for all event
that you guys have been doing the
blood-borne speedrun was awesome that
was hey-zeus his toast and who did that
and he says and love breeze let's plays
the life is strange ones are my favorite
glad a gamer got to be error that's so
sweet
that's very sweet thank you to everyone
who has donated so far a lot of
donations we have we've had and they
were all money's going to crucial some
valuable causes another shout out to the
strange rebel community who's been
hanging out chatting being awesome in
their in their Twitter and YouTube chats
being awesome is something they're very
good at for sure I love the way you just
push that kid out of the way there I did
I didn't mean to I tried to go around
and said I just shoved him sold your way
sometimes you go push a kid out of ways
to get stuff done
oh he's over here where is the guy he's
over here got it I'm shoving a lot of
people yes it's copied unknown right
they know you're American like yeah
they're obviously not you with the six
foot sword
yeah the giant knife guy is back and
he's running towards you just let him
just let him push you it see if I get
pushed I'll he pulls out the J knife and
you'd rather take the push I love
watching these videos of people remaking
fantasy final fantasy weapons but in
real life and obviously there's been a
few blacksmiths making the Buster Sword
and it's terrifying like this huge burly
man and they can barely lift it cuz it's
just chunk of metal and along comes
chicken arms cloud this this whole quest
line with the kids I really love and
then the challenge they set you to do
they like the smash the boxes thing I
call weirdly obsessed with that it was
it was very really fun for me yeah I had
a really hard time with it at first
because I thought it was related to the
strength of your abilities
I didn't realize it's actually related
to choosing your boxes more carefully
hmm which ones to go after so once I
figured that out it was it was much
easier yeah there's that strategy of
like placing yourself in between two
stacks so you can hit both of them yeah
so like once you nail that it's a little
easier but it's still really tricky it's
where the timer boxes are once you
figure that's a lot easier because it
helps guide your path so that you can be
the most time-efficient
yeah exactly it's weird how like the
hardest parts of this game are like
besides stuff that you don't really have
to concern yourself with like the
destroying the boxes and the other thing
is like that's the pull-up challenge
which is like it's unbelievable like
I've the bosses in the game are way
easier and the pull-up time comes along
I'm like okay I'm gonna make this quick
to defeat the pull-up challenge I don't
I still haven't done it
like I really yeah yeah I was like I
caught it I it was stressing me out
my leg you know you get into like weird
I started getting like weird tunnel
vision oh yeah you're just pressing it
like in a rhythm and I have like my
wrist starts to hurt it's like basically
carpal tunnel and like they repeated
like same motion of doing the thing it
was just starting to hurt my wrist I was
like you know what it's not worth
destroying my arm that's fair it reminds
me of when I used to play like Guitar
Hero and the second if you'd play it for
a couple hours you'd look away and then
your vision would start scrolling up and
you're like wait a minute yeah it's the
same of like if you play what was it the
other one that did that for me like
Assassin's Creed was like that where you
start seeing things that you could
potentially climb after having scale the
buildings for like 70 hours I'm trying
to go for the persona 5 royal platinum
because it's quite easy to do it's just
basically play the game they changed it
completely from persona 5 and there's
one trophy that I was always in the back
of my head which was you go to the
bathhouse on a foggy rainy day hmm and I
was thinking about that because I'm
trying to do like time management to hit
everything that I need and it was foggy
and raining here in San Francisco I
looked outside the window and I
genuinely thought to myself I should get
that achievement tonight perfect I'm
like no as much as you want it to be I
just oh god I'd live in persona world
and I had the same thing with Animal
Crossing when it was in real life I'd be
like oh good I don't have to water my
flowers today when video games become
too real when worlds collide yeah same
for me I've got this dog who keeps
hounding me about money all the time
ready for training well let me build
anything with those permissions all
right Lucy it's time oh okay you ready
mm-hmm
is it a final fancy summon or have I
pulled this strange creatures name from
somewhere else entirely door Thor the a
u th l doleful audio fee the da u th I
[Music]
say he's a magic card oh you are so good
at this
geez well so I felt like if that was
Final Fantasy you would have known how
to pronounce it I'm I'm the problem here
you are
it was too many Magic the Gathering
cards and a lot of them are nonsense
like so many there's some absolutely
tragically named Magic the Gathering
cards by the way like badger that's all
about but to be fair though badgers are
quite terrifying I don't know like well
honey badgers especially honey badgers
are the scary regular Badgers are just
badgers got massive claws I'm always
just worried that's a good thing to be
around wild animals just in general yeah
it's honey badgers are while ostriches
yeah dinosaurs yeah it's a little longer
no fan of anything that can kick you
like that and there's this one Canadian
town somewhere at some point where it
got basically taken over for a few days
by ostriches which I remember watching
the video of and I was both the most
funniest thing I'd ever seen and also
the most terrifying thing I'd ever seen
because it was like look at all these
ostriches and then it would cut to like
someone's camera from inside a car where
they cannot leave because there's like
five ostriches circling their car and
like taking out the windows I've ever
heard yeah it's it's terrifying all
right how much would make a game about
ostriches
that the the untile goose game but we
have an ostrich that's the logical
sequel yeah that's the sequel untitled
ostrich game yeah we have about 10
months left of the stream which is comes
CLE yeah oh no he's just chatting to you
and playground fancy Breanna I ran so
much for joining us
yeah I've only been paying attention to
the game because I've just been chatting
away these these area of effect ones
really got me I really struggled with
this stuff maybe I always want to fight
with Erath even when Aerith is not the
best call hmm yeah I had that with Erika
aunty but yeah I would I would always
switch between Aerith and kefir because
just I found him to be a really good
combo with the kind of lock them in
place with the crystal and then just get
in with t-34 and do like area-of-effect
stuff and combos but it just meant that
cloud and barriers got relegated to yeah
you switch is sad but it's fine
I hate those imp in amis especially the
ones that jump on your head for like
half an hour time aim is wild and took
me ages to realise how to be in at the
moment they came up I just get
incredibly frustrated yeah there is
classic oh I do have thunder okay let's
just knock that guy out oh I'm sorry in
the chat the je-vc 95 ostriches gay
graze on the lawn of Brazil's
presidential palace and are used as
animal bodyguards right animal Birds
how are you trusting your life to a
ostrich that is wild
I believe it I mean I would not mess
with a ostrich at all and like you can't
even it's really hard to like if you are
like some I'm so
the fasting I'm gonna snipe someone or
power from a distance an ostrich is
really hard to hit like in legs
thin thin neck like it's got a chunky
buddy but like always on the move yeah
Wow Super Why and the chat says it's
free if you could pick any animal
bodyguard which one would you pick an
animal bodyguard one that was super
intimidating but also I enjoyed its
presence ooh a bear of some sort maybe
so here's the thing my favorite animals
are pandas and that's right yeah those
are terrible animals they're about
everything yeah that's true so bad at
everything they're bad at procreation
they're bad at eating nutritious food
mm-hmm they don't really they're not
really predators they only use their
massive strong muscley jaws for chewing
bamboo because it's such a bad food and
they fall from everything all the time
so like Panda is great to have around
super adorable but not good defense of
animals body they get duped a lot cuz
don't zookeepers dress up like pandas
zookeeper ever a lot of animals actually
they don't wanna accustom wild animals
to human presence and so they often
dress up as the animal to just at least
not be human-like which i think is
fascinating yeah um you know I would
probably go with some type of large cat
mm-hmm us feel like my spirit animal is
like a leopard so definitely probably do
a large cat like a leopard or a jack
that's pretty good yeah Lucy um maybe
it's because I've been watching so much
avatar I would say maybe a lemur similar
to Momo um because actually one of the
cool things I've cause things I've ever
done is
fed some lemurs and they kind of clamber
all over you and they are very cute and
very sweet and so I would I would like a
lemur please not keen on that I don't
love wild animal human experiences just
enroll when you say like be wary of wild
animals like even loopers could take
your ear off I would hate that it was I
don't know they was a very like
controlled thing and honestly like my
views I think after having watched Tiger
King against zoos and stuff has
completely changed in recent years this
is when I was much much younger very
true um but like I don't I've never
considered a lemur really a threatening
kind of animal like horses like a horse
has messed up my system before my sister
rode horses a lot as a kid and she got
stood on which in the grand scheme of
potential horse injuries is not as bad
as you know getting kicked but it still
broke a few of her toes
Oh kidding that's I think so I was a
bigger
arch and because there in like any TV
shows and stuff we forget that but words
are very large animals they it's
affected um it's it's like some some
breeds of dog - that will muscle yeah
that's true
so no horse bodyguard for me no as long
as use a little scamp and like just a
Momo s Colima my favorite animals are
crows I really like crows as a bird but
they wouldn't be good for like defending
me or they'd be good for like scaring
people off if it just like Corder
everyone you need a large amount and
then terrifying if I had a murder of
crows one I could I would just defend
myself by saying I'm gonna unleash my
murder of crows it would be yeah I'll be
there but if I had to pick like a
defensive animal a 100% biggest snake no
one's yeah like snake on sight people
are terrified like oh my god like if you
pick like a king cobra or something like
like you know if you want to find me you
got to get past my snake snake doesn't
even have to actually attack it just
needs to like slither around and people
are like I'm good man
duck a combine snake and crow I'm a
business
no one's ever touching me ever really
want is a chimera yeah I need a kind of
I need a chimera that's a great idea
we need sadly I only have a couple
minutes left
um which is actually pretty good you
just wrapped up that fight very very
Heatley yeah um so just you know let's
oh no it's really sad to think of why
this has been so lovely Brianna and like
I know Tom and I have talked about this
like 5-7 remake has been a standout game
of the year so far so it's been really
nice to get this insight from you and
thank you so much to have to your
community for like joining us on the
stream asking fun questions and like
really getting involved in the chat it's
been lovely so thank you to everyone and
thank you everyone who's donated - yeah
thank you so much yeah as you know the
links are on the screen anyone who
hasn't who feels inclined to can donate
we obviously raising money for black
last man and co-ed relief efforts and
yeah as Lucy said just to reiterate
thank you so much to you Briana for
coming on and doing this I know you're
incredibly busy and you have a lot of
streaming that you do so the fact that
you are able to come over and hang out
with us for a bit and it means a lot to
us and also for you bringing your
community which is proven yourself to be
as lovely as we imagined it to be but
yeah thank you to everyone for showing
up and hanging out for a bit and we're
continuing to do these streams every day
pretty much so if you're here and you
enjoyed what you saw feel free to come
back tomorrow we'll have more streams we
also cover the major events that are
happening over the next few weeks are
going to be raising money through June
into early July so yeah if you if you
have some time to kill and want to hang
out with some friends we're here for you
this is a wonderfully fun time like I
said even though I have just played
through this part of the game it is
equally enjoyable playing it again
and I love that you guys have put
together this this event um I'm sure it
was a lot of work it's been it's been
worth it honestly just like yeah hang
out with people like you who we wouldn't
get to see otherwise so thank you again
so much for joining us everyone else
we'll be back again tomorrow with Jake
Baldino from game ranks if you'd like to
join us then thank you so much for
watching and donating bye everyone
[Music]
[Music]